from hospitals and at homes to wherever
they work doctors and nurses worldwide
are battling was described as the
invisible enemy they should be using
what's known as personal protective
equipment including medical masks gowns
gloves and eye protection some designed
for single use and immediate disposal
more cases mean more discarded gear more
medical supplies used and that means
medical waste on a scale never seen
before the problem is really to to find
a place an area where we can store and
parallel temporarily the containers that
contain those all those used and
contaminated equipment this is really
the main the main issue figures from
China showed that when the pandemic was
at its peak in February hundred and
fifty nine thousand tons of medical
waste were disposed off in six weeks
since late January 240 tons of that was
from Wuhan alone every day China had to
construct a medical waste plant to cope
with many patients recovering at home
and some were infected but show no
symptoms workers who collect household
refuse are also at risk if you have to
tell people to avoid throwing trash in
piles like that it would be better if
they put it in bags that maybe avoid
touching as much as possible and we
award the risk of getting infected with
corona virus and other diseases as the
u.s. joins other countries and
recommending wearing masks not disposing
of them safely increases infection dress
scrubbers can say or outside the
surgical mask for seven days as long as
seven days so if you're a sick person
the contaminated side is the size of the
MassDEP facing you so you've rolled it
up fold up the size that that facing you
if your healthcare workers to
contaminate decide is the size of Master
with color the size that phasing out the
outside environment so you try to fold
it up and other
in a world besieged by the commune of
Arras the expert advises the health risk
can be reduced but only if everyone
follows the rules Priyanka Gupta
al-jazeera